all right next up I've got Carol on the
line
Carol is calling from Indiana Carol how
are you good how are you sir all I'm
focused are not finished what's on your
mind huh no recently got introduced to
you guys through my sister and we have a
little discussion going on about credit
card I feel like I benefit from the
credit card we only my husband and I
only have one and then to take vacations
for for a year I don't for free yeah
well that's what I mean is the point
ticket so I pay $100 a year fee for the
credit card but a monthly basis we put
about seven thousand a month always pay
it off because we do all of our monthly
budgeting bills everything is inclusive
and that is equal that to about eighty
four thousand points a year and I at
least get three round-trip tickets a
year with those points okay so if you
switch that's a number that's at least
600 dollars a year and I'm only paying
$100 fee I feel like I'm making $500 off
this credit card oh you're making money
what magical is that you have this is
the United all right and you all have
been doing that no I'm actually the
Southwest we just switched to United
okay how long have you been doing this
you know I've been doing this for the
last eight years because my husband was
in medical school and we couldn't afford
traveling and try wow this is a good way
to travel for free and so your sister is
telling you what what's the debate
what's the question because you have a
magic card this year is yeah I feel like
I'm I I appreciate what you guys do but
I feel like I'm we are one of the wise
couples that looks to benefit this is
wills new card
what's your net worth right now our net
worth huh
probably 400 okay well I don't know what
you mean by network out of medical
school right well I mean
probably yeah yeah well here's the
reality what I mean by net worth is you
take everything that you own - anything
that you owe on and so you add that up
that's a net worth I'm gonna tell you
this ninety-eight percent of people
aren't paying off the credit cards each
and every month and I can tell you
something else
this is my mic drop moment people I talk
to over ten thousand millionaires I ask
him how they got there guess how many
told me it was because of points and
rewards and miles not a one so honey you
keep your unicorn card and you do what
you need to do the rest of the people
out there that are focused and not
finished pay them things off shut them
down and live your life this is the Dave
Ramsey show
[Music]